and since you do have a business
background and now you're taking this
new filmmaking journey and I believe
you've also formed a company or you
going to be releasing you know
consciousness-raising films or films
that were more to the higher mindset how
did those how did that intuitive mind
that you have helped you venture into
this new area well it really goes to
that issue of trust and just just saying
there's a there's an opening here as
improbable as it would seem and I'm
going and I got that feeling it's it's
the heart intuition that works with the
mind and the gut intuition says trust
this just just ask so I did that from my
banking background my head would have
said you have to write an investment
memorandum and you've gotta fit you got
to get investors into this film that
have a sort of all these number
crunching things to know if I put this
much in the film I have a potential
getting this much back but then another
one of my supporters had just asked I
had a very loyal following of people
that in that really were drawn to my
intuitive work and I asked them would
you guys support me in making this film
about the sacred journey of the heart
and in five days I raised 150 thousand
dollars people just wrote me pretty big
checks and then in my world you know the
individual this is not big companies
that was a lot and so I trusted and I
said that's the green light I meant to
go ahead is improbable as it was so we
did
you